Ils nous lâchent pas !
Ils en font une affaire personnelle !
Roman, on est là pour faire diversion, rien de plus !
T'as tout pété en route !
T'espérais quoi, je suis Roman Pierce quoi, merde !
C'est ma "touch" !
Phase 2 !
Phase 2 ?! C'est quoi la phase 2 ?!
De la bombe !
Nom de... !
Tu sais ce que j'aime chez toi, Dom ?
Tu es un vrai hors-la-loi.
Et ta famille ?
Joli travail, mon frère ! Une fois à la base, je paye ma tournée !
Elle va devoir affronter le seul truc qu'elle ne peut pas vaincre.
Toi.
Tu aurais imaginé trahir ta famille comme tu l'as fait aujourd'hui ?
Dominic Toretto... s'est retourné contre nous.
Tiens tiens, regardez qui est là !
Je sais pas pourquoi il le fait, mais ça peut pas être Dom.
Elle est l'incarnation même du terrorisme high-tech.
Et maintenant, elle collabore avec votre homme.
Je crois que j'ai trouvé mon équipe.
Ça, ça m'intéresse.
Vous voulez jouer à ça ?
Ouille.
C'est impossible.
C'est pourquoi il vous faudra un petit coup de main.
Je vais te mettre la branlée de ta vie !
Ah, ça a pris plus de temps que je le pensais.
Si vous voulez choper Dom, vous allez devoir bosser ensemble.
Surprise !
J'suis raide dingue.
Depuis le temps que j'en rêve ! On a un tank !
En voiture !
Et les voilà...
Je sais pas si Dom, le vrai, est dans le coin, mais je m'en tape.
Je vais te mettre minable, Toretto.
On va s'amuser.
Pourquoi ils m'allument tous ?!
Je sais pas, peut-être parce que t'as une Lamborghini orange ?
Me saoule pas, Tej !
Oh la vache !
Il nous faudrait un plus gros camion !
Dom !
Tu comptes vraiment lâcher ta famille ?
On va s'amuser.